we begin this morning with the
continuing questions about the response
to the florida school shooting and the
ongoing debate over gun safety there are
reports this morning that at least three
Broward County sheriff's deputies waited
outside Marjory Stoneman Douglas High
School
while a gunman killed 17 people inside
that includes a school resource officer
who resigned on Thursday last week's
shooting has prompted calls at the state
and national level for changes to gun
laws and security measures at schools
Omar Villafranca is outside Stoneman
Douglas High School in parkland Florida
Omar good morning good morning Governor
Rick Scott says he wants to make it
virtually impossible for anyone with the
mental health issue to use a gun
meanwhile CBS News has confirmed that a
woman close to the alleged shooter
called the FBI on January 5th and warned
them that she was concerned that
Nicholas Cruz would quote get into a
school and just shoot the place up I'd
rather have somebody that loves their
students and wants to protect their
students then somebody's standing
outside that doesn't know anybody and
doesn't know the students and frankly
for whatever reason decided not to go in
even though we heard lots of shots being
fired at CPAC on Friday President Trump
once again called for arming gun adept
teachers to keep students safe mr. Trump
said he would rather see educators with
concealed carry permits than armed
officers like deputy Scott Peterson who
had a chance to stop alleged shooter
Nicholas Cruz but did not the teacher
would have shot the hell out of him
before we knew what happened but that
was not part of Florida Governor Rick
Scott Action Plan announced Friday gonna
have law enforcement every school and
we're gonna look at the size of campuses
but at least a you know you know one for
every thousand students but law
enforcement do the keeping us safe and
let teachers focus on teaching governor
Scott also proposed a violent threat
restraining order that would prevent a
violent person like Cruz from having a
gun if evidence of a threat is presented
in court
who's kicked out of school who is known
to students as a danger to shoot people
and he was reported to the FBI last
month as a possible school shooter and
yet he was never put on the list to be
denied the ability to buy a gun and his
guns were never removed from him CBS
News has confirmed a woman called an FBI
tip line concerned Nicholas Cruz would
get into a school and just shoot the
place up
she said he had a diminished mental
capacity and gave a stark warning you
know it's just so much I know he's he's
going to explode it was very somber
some people were emotional Marjory
Stoneman Douglas social studies teacher
Greg Pittman was one of the staff
members who returned to the school
Friday he says he is a gun owner but
says guns and classrooms are a quote
very bad idea on top of that I want to
be a teacher I do not want to be police
I don't want to be swiped I do not want
to be the army if I did that I would
have joined that I had going here they
sewed that up
shrapnel here here in here 12th grade
shooting survivor Samantha Fuentes plans
to complete her education online so that
she can advocate for stricter gun
control but that doesn't mean she's
concerned about returning to campus I
want to return to a safe place a safe
country for all of our children and
their children and their children and
the only way to do that is to step back
on campus and tell the world no I will
not to be defeated by this I will not be
turned away I will be listened to on
Sunday students can go to an open house
it's on campus and they can ask for help
on Monday and Tuesday staff is expected
to return and classes are expected to
resume on Wednesday Anthony
Omar Villafranca and parkland Florida
thanks Omar